here's a good one should I kick my
neighbors ass yes
generally speaking hey bill love the
podcast no that's East Coast okay that's
why people [ __ ] where the [ __ ] is a
podcast um I need some advice on what to
do about the gut this guy who lives in a
few houses down for me I'm a third-year
college student and I live at home my
parents moved to go live in the state
above mine
you mean north and I currently reside
alone while they are trying to sell the
house a few months ago I was driving
home coming back from a gym and while I
was driving in my neighborhood I saw
this guy step in the middle of the road
about 20 yards from my car he was
yelling something at me but I couldn't
hear what he was saying I slowed down
and stopped my car right in front of him
and he came to my window and told me to
get out I was totally confused and
thought I'd run over I thought I ran
over his cat or something also I think
he just moved in because I never seen
the do in my life so I rolled down the
window and asked what did you say he
goes I'm gonna kick your [ __ ] ass get
out of the car this guy's probably in
his 40s and has to be around 510 is that
business me 250 pounds That's not me
I'm 21 6-3 200 I do CrossFit and I
wrestle occasionally at another gym I go
to so I get out of the car and I'm
standing there trying to figure out what
the hell is going on the guy starts
moving towards me so I take the
initiative and take a step towards him
we end up being an inch from each other
and he's trying to do some alpha male
[ __ ] by just staring at me but I have
the height advantage so I'm looking down
at him at least 10 seconds go by before
the guy goes how fast do you think you
were going back there I say I don't know
probably around 30 the speed limit my
neighborhood is 20 and I know I wasn't
going that much over it then he goes I'm
not gonna have my children playing in
the yard if I know [ __ ] like you are
driving like that in the neighborhood
after he said that I saw his wife and
son were a little off to the side of the
road once the word [ __ ] left his
mouth I was [ __ ] pissed I wanted to
just tackle the dick and put him to
leap in front of his wife and kid to
teach him a lesson but I pussied out and
just apologize to him and said that I
was really Sully sorry and it wouldn't
happen again the guy then gives me a
[ __ ] little smirk and turns around
and says while walking away with his
back turned it better not or you know
what will happen oh yeah definitely
should I kicked his ass what a good do
you realize what this kid did he's such
a [ __ ] gentleman he could have kicked
the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of this guy he saw
his wife and kid there it would have
been emasculating his dad is Superman he
sits there you know it is it's that
little smirk yeah that [ __ ] smirk I
bet that [ __ ] steals from work yeah I
bet he does sorry dude that's the first
time I really had to walk away you
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah you should have kicked
that guy's ass but it's a good I don't
he definitely has this many rights now
after that that [ __ ] I wanted to explode
I mean the guy totally disrespected me
so I get in my car and drive off and the
story wrong
I couldn't get this [ __ ] guy out of
my head dude I can't get it out of my
head I'm gonna actually fantasize that I
was there and he did that what I would
want to do I've already you know I would
[ __ ] do I would wait till he was
alone don't do this [ __ ] don't do this
but I know what you just want to get it
get the guy alone and be like hey what
are you gonna do now huh what are you
gonna do now just get right in his
[ __ ] grill and have him back down or
I would almost do say the guys say hey
listen man just come over the car and
just say listen I just wanted you to
know the other day that if I wanted to I
could have [ __ ] stuffed you in my
trunk tied you up like a [ __ ] pretzel
and ass raped you in front of your
[ __ ] wife but I chose not to okay cuz
I didn't want your son to know what a
little [ __ ] I can't say it [ __ ] he
has four that would have been homophobic
either
I wouldn't even be talking about gay
people that's such a [ __ ] [ __ ] move
yeah and if for some reason but but I'm
put up no then that's what you say maybe
you do it like Columbo just say listen
man I gotta ask you something
cuz I'm 6 foot 3 I CrossFit I wrestle ok
and just looking at you I know I could
tie into a pretzel I know I could do it
if I wanted to but the confidence you
had I just want to know what what is
your background you know cuz you know
I'm a real competitive guy you know if
you got some sort of martial arts
training you know I would love to have
you once we don't you come down to the
gym sometime when your wife and kid
aren't there so I have to feel guilty
when I [ __ ] you up and close both your
eyes with this one and it's friend over
here I know because that's what's
happening now this is what happens when
you do the right thing in life okay when
you know it eats away at you you have to
make peace you have to make peace and
and you got to tell yourself the lie
that some day this guy's gonna get his
and you know what he doesn't guys like
this don't get theirs oh that's smart I
think this kid really painted a [ __ ]
picture I can just his driving me nuts
he goes I couldn't get this guy out of
my head a week went by and I was still
thinking about that [ __ ] dude I would
think about this guy 20 years from now
two weeks later I was driving home from
school and I see the guy rolling his
garbage can out to the curb I slowed
down to [ __ ] under 20 and I know this
because I looked down at my speedometer
speedometer I pretend to stare the guy
down so I look at him and he looks at me
and yells slow down Wow now when he said
that I am [ __ ] raging I wanted to
stop my car and do some ground-and-pound
on his face yeah this kid knows what
he's doing this isn't wrestling like
this kids doing UFC [ __ ] but did I know
I just drove off like a [ __ ] the next day
I talked to my friend about it about
what had happened and he said that this
guy said the same [ __ ] to him if he said
it he would have put him on his ass I
know
do you know what I would have done he
told me that if he says he's going to
kick your ass then that's a threat so
you can defend yourself don't listen to
your dumb friend he's saying you won't
get arrested so a few months have passed
and I'm still thinking about this
[ __ ] every time I Drive by his house
fast forward to yesterday and I'm I'm
biking in my neighborhood listen to an
IHOP and I hear a honk from behind me so
I pull my bike over to the side of the
road and it's none other than the same
dude in his Ford f-150 driving along and
he looks at me and gives me the middle
[ __ ] finger Wow now granted I was in
the middle of the road and didn't hear
the guy coming because I was listening
to music but still the middle finger so
I biked home take a shower and try to
convince myself to walk over the dudes
house and confront him but after a
couple minutes of pacing I just decided
to wait it out until the [ __ ] does
one more thing I mean I don't want to
get arrested so my question is what the
hell should I do
I mean every time I Drive by this guy's
house now I want a [ __ ] veer off the
road and ran my car into the middle of
his living room
any advice would be good all of my
friends think I should go over there but
I want a second opinion you can't do
anything to this guy unless he puts his
hands on you this is just one of these
things but you can do to him what he's
doing to you this guy has an insane
temper so uh you know I'm not advocating
legally so you don't do this but like I
don't know what I'm next time you know
if you see him out in the yard or
something this is what you do I have a
great idea do you have any friends who
are really good mechanically why don't
you take your credit card out go down to
the [ __ ] Auto store or whatever I'll
go online and buy like one of those
[ __ ] train horns and have it
installed in your car and next time you
drive down the street just be sort of
zigzagging down the street just to get
this guy to be [ __ ] you know getting
all like what I [ __ ] the second he
starts screaming you lay on that [ __ ]
horn as loud as humanly possible and you
blow out his eardrums that's what I was
but then again then no one douche like
this he would say that I
permanent hearing damage you know what I
think you should do maybe because I'm a
female and I'm all about cycle revenge
okay psychological warfare what should
you do I think when the husband is not
home I don't know if how if he knows the
schedule or whatever he needs to go over
there when the wife is at home and be
like listen you know I'm so sorry about
that time that I was speeding I really
you know but your your husband seems
really upset I'm really not trying to be
like that I would never do anything like
that in women are oh no no cuz she knows
her husband is a psycho I mean she could
turn around and be like yeah you
shouldn't do that either but I have a
feeling she's not like that and he can
just go over and just make nice and be
like the sweet kid that's helping out or
would you need me to take the husband
and he's like sitting there sipping tea
with the wife you know I don't know you
know it's a great thing to do and then
[ __ ] the wife no no he should [ __ ] his
wife he should play with his kid in the
backyard like the toss the football
around with him be more like there's
nothing like just start giving them the
finger listen this is deal all you got
to do is just give him the finger give
him the finger right back
cuz this guy thinks you're a [ __ ] right
now so all you gotta do is you know you
can just yell back just say you know
just give him the finger yell back at
him when he's in the driveway I would
like swerve at him and then swerve back
just [ __ ] with the guy he's mean just do
that once because the next time you
might have like a video camera but I I
just don't want to get any I don't get
any you know what if I was in that
situation dude you know what I would do
yeah
Oh morning quarterback look when I was
in that situation with that other guy
right yeah but the last place we lived
and I didn't [ __ ] with him because he
was an old guy I just didn't [ __ ] with
him and now we found out he has dementia
and all this [ __ ] so I'm psyched
I never yelled at the guy you know what
you do now you know what what really
diffuses angry guys like that or makes
them even more angry
it's just laugh at him just keep
laughing at him
laughs Adam give him the finger and just
keep calling him tough guy all right
that tough guy anything anything you
just keep calling them anything that is
remotely all right there Chuck Norris
anything you want to say to this guy
that will bait him into hitting you this
isn't really a [ __ ] this is a great
question and I don't want to get in
trouble if some [ __ ] goes down so you
shouldn't do anything sir wink wink wink
this guy's such a dick I know I always
say you know [ __ ] with somebody's car
was like a [ __ ] move but this guy's
such a dick and he has like such a oh my
god dude how many times you thought
about throat - just choke slam and that
guy run into the hood of your car
repeatedly nobody if you just said it
really calmly if you said it calmly with
sort of a smile on your face you come
off like a [ __ ] maniac
yeah that's true if you scream that at
somebody you just sound like you're
quoting like you know Hulk Hogan or
something right let me tell you
something brother come to Saturday
benjin up Russell in a scrape you